let's let's hit a couple stories all at
once we got this from newsbusters
from brian stelter over at cnn peter
ducey provoked biden
fox worse for america america than sob
insult so let's slow down so this is a
story about uh it was peter ducey right
yeah so he's a journalist and he asked
biden on the way out of this conference
or whatever this he was just like is is
inflation a political liability joe
biden not realizing that his mic was
still on he said uh he's like you know
inflation what a great asset asset what
a stupid son of a [ __ ] about uh peter
ducey apparently uh ducey said that
biden called him and you know said it
was nothing personal pal or whatever and
you know effectively apologized fox was
particularly gracious they were like
okay you know we're over it
and now brian stelter is saying ducey
provoked him it's because they have to
yeah that's because they have to have
the narrative of the enemy
these people are our enemy these people
are evil and i'm just like this is
exactly why the corporate press is a
flame and spiraling out of control and
it's in less than 12 hours that the
narrative has changed last night in his
newsletter with oliver darcy faux former
conservative reporter turned brian
stelter mini-me uh the two of them had a
bit about this and stelter says well
we're not really gonna spend a lot of
time on this because it's not worth our
time and there's a lot more important
things going on here's what happened
it's wrong the end and and so in less
than 12 hours we've gone from that to
they're doing multiple cnn segments
about it and brian stelter saying what
ducey asked was a provocation even
though
jake tapper said on jimmy kimmel last
night that the question was very fairly
aerodyne
like it was do you believe that
inflation is going to be a political
liability for you
with the midterms i do think i i think
man
part of me wants to say it's a dumb
question to ask because we all know the
answer to it correct yeah but it proved
to be a very very good question to ask
right well and ducey has explained this
by saying that okay so it was a meeting
of the white house competition council
about the economy and most of his
cabinet was there
and he gave him remarks about the
economy so then reporters started
shouting him questions about ukraine and
russia and he expressed
annoyance at that that nobody was asking
him questions about the economy so ducey
is hey i've got a you know question are
you taking questions about the economy
and then he shouted his question about
inflation so ducey was on topic
what biden wanted to talk about
and he gave that reaction i kind of get
it because if his question is like hey
biden is inflation bad like it's like
are you are you insulting my
intelligence dude like i get why biden
might have reacted like that but this is
a chance for joe to come out and be like
hey america hey everybody i'm sorry
about the way i reacted i'm under a lot
of stress this is
unprecedented what we're experiencing is
a human race bear with why why is it
that we can say that exact line ian but
they don't why is that we can be like yo
just come out and be like let me just be
honest with you guys so when we had the
ceo of get around the show
we then had the ceo of gab on the show
and i think it was andrew torba he said
if the ceo of getter came out and just
like look we banned nick fuentes because
we're under a lot of pressure from these
big corporations who are trying to shut
us down and we were effectively forced
to do it and we're unhappy about it
that's the reality of the situation
people would have been like wow i think
it sucks but i respect him for being
honest and said he's just like no he
broke the rules we banned him it's like
he couldn't even answer the question i
don't understand why it is that people
can't just be completely straightforward
hey we had to do this like we're we're
hands our hands are tied and we're
unhappy you know what i mean yeah and
how relieved would brian's everyone
would be and then we could just move on
if brian stelter's came out and said i
am a paid hack who jeff zucker tells me
to
you know wake up every day and talk
about how fox news is the enemy of the
people you know
it would be totally fine i understand
why brian selter would never do anything
like that and it's different from like
you know ian saying biden could have
been like
you know he could have he could he could
come out later and be like yeah i'm
sorry for doing that snapping man um
it's a stressful job you have to
understand and just be like really
straightforward the thing about brian
stelter though is there's a difference
between
you know a president who's trying to
maintain an image
and a guy who's paid to maintain an
image so you know look joe biden's
trying to save face he may or may not
come out and be honest about why he
reacted that way brian stelter was hired
specifically to lie to people so he
would never be honest about his position
because it would just completely upend
his entire career well into your point
about joe joe could have framed it in a
kind of a folksy way he could have said
yeah not
well even though nothing personal but he
could have just said it and he could
come out and said yeah i'm under a lot
of stress you know this country's facing
a lot of challenges but we're gonna get
through it together you know i asked for
your prayers and support uh you know
you know anything
you ever see that movie with robin
williams where he's basically like john
stewart running for president what was
that what was that no no no that's not
men of the people or something no no
what was it called you know what i'm
talking about right
she's like robin williams plays as
comedian and then he announces gonna run
for president
and then everyone he starts winning but
then it turns out there's like a glitch
in the system man of the year man of the
year it was actually kind of creepy
propaganda if you watch it because it's
basically at the time there was that
joke about jon stewart and stephen
colbert running for president because
everyone was really excited about it
yeah not colbert you know but jon
stewart's all right but uh everyone was
really excited and they make this movie
where it's like robin williams is like
it was really bad that i would run
and become president or whatever but but
anyway you know i bring up this movie
because in it the reason he does really
well is because he's candid with people
he's honest and he just says it and he's
he's sick and tired of the machine then
there's also that movie bullworth you
ever see bullworth
no i've heard of that though um
bullworth that's the movie where the guy
he's a senator and he wants to kill
himself so he just starts he hires an
assassin to to end his own life and so
he's just like at these meetings and
he's just saying everything exactly as
everyone knows he goes to a black church
and they're like last time you came and
campaigned you promised xyz why didn't
you fulfill those promises and he's like
well because you voted for us and you're
not going to vote for anybody else i
mean come on let's be real
oh my god it's an amazing movie but
people they they end up loving him
and then he wants to live or whatever
but why is it that in in our culture we
understand that we just are desperate
for someone to be honest to to say the
things we all know to be true to finally
admit it when you are lying cheating and
stealing you know like
how many viewers does brian stelter get
seven like let's let's be honest 80 000
maybe he he has yeah he has on some
sundays pulled in in the demo
about 80 000. 80 000 demo yeah like
nobody is watching this guy
at a certain point i have to wonder it's
like why even bother it's like imagine
building a bridge and then like the end
of the bridge just goes straight to a
brick wall it's like why did you build
that so why is he doing this show like
it's just it's ridiculous i so i hear we
are talking about the guy constantly i
just i'm i'm wondering when we're gonna
break into that moment where i think
we're getting there with with shows like
joe rogan's show with shows like this
where we just have an honest and i don't
mean like revealing secrets about
military and stuff like that within
reason i mean like someone literally
like imagine if you got a government
official and they were like a video was
released by julian assange showing a
drone strike killing civilians and he
said
i wish there i wish i could tell all the
american people every single thing that
goes on
but uh there's a reason why we have
confidential stuff and there's a lot of
really disgusting things the american
american military has done that i think
if the american people found out about
they'd be very angry but also people
realize that you know there are you know
people who are trying their best to keep
americans safe and that means warfare is
a gruesome blood now that's a hard sell
for the american if the people knew how
we were using white phosphorus and
fallujah in iraq how they were using it
as an incandescent to light up the
scenery but what it's actually doing is
melting human skin of the civilians on
the ground that they're sh exploding it
over if people knew that we were melting
the skin of the civilians in iraq when
we were there it would have been a
different narrative and if they found
out today i think it would be pretty
jarring but but i'm saying like if a guy
came out and said here's why we can't
talk about some of this stuff because if
you realized what we did in your name
this country probably couldn't survive
that that this country
this this country is where we are
wealthy we are comfortable
and then you when you have to learn
about the things that this country has
done and you're like it's kind of
disgusting obama killed kids you know a
lot of them and no americans going to
vote in favor of that so they try and
keep it hush-hush i can understand
when they're like it's top secrets
confidential and you know we believe
we're doing good personally i i don't
think that's i think they're not doing
good all the time i think there's a lot
of corruption i think they do you know
weapons deals for the sake of weapons
deals but my point is more so like
they come out and they say freedom you
know it's evil people who hate freedom
and it's just like shut up
like there's oil fields in syria we
understand why you don't want trump
pulling the troops out you know
maybe i i just overestimate the average
person the fact that there are democrats
who buy into all this stuff and keep
believing it
says a lot but maybe maybe that's
breaking maybe maybe it's breaking it's
slowly but surely i think you know um
especially now that trump you know is
not in the oval office he's not
president it's like sitting there
that's joe biden is at the lever here
that he's the president and he's running
the show whether you like it or not and
uh they have other they have to figure
out other things and now
that's why they continue to focus on
things like january 6th so that trump is
still a dominant picture so we don't
want to see what's going on over here
with joe biden
and
i think enough people are starting to
see through that that it's like
p and people as i've said before want
all kinds of topics covered in their
news coverage and they want their
politicians to be very versatile and be
able to answer these questions like you
guys have talked about um
that really span the spectrum instead of
just going down these boilerplate things
that i think people realize that we may
have done this to ourselves but that
doesn't mean we can't find our way out
of it
i think i think we're winning you know
yeah yeah the ratings collapse
the machine is desperately trying to
prop up these shows youtube props up
these big networks because they have to
because you know they have this big this
billion dollar multi-billion dollar
machine to propagandize and manipulate
and it's not working you got people in
their bathrooms on their phones getting
more views
yeah and the way you look at it is yeah
these networks almost
it's this partnership with these
networks that you know what's to say if
that youtube and these social media
platforms didn't do what they said that
there would be
you know that we're going to report
negatively on you the same you know you
want us to go fox news or you know the
way other platforms did on
uh you guys i don't think so it's the
symbiotic relationship where they think
they need each other to survive um yeah
and that's why they're pushing all these
you know new networks onto youtube and
streaming platforms cnn plus are you
kidding me um
you know that they have lured away all
of this talent chris wallace oh chris
wallace jake tapper's gonna do a book
show
interviewing authors
um they hired a host from npr you know
they hired rex chapman um it's tiring
it's tiring but they're doing it because
they are continuing to try and survive
where you know you know you've now
entered our marketplace this marketplace
youtube and social media platforms so
that they can push everyone else out
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time